hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
july 18 2022
[Music]
2022
what's going on
how the [ __ ] are you i hope everything's
good with you and in your world
and whatnot i hope you're staying cool
i hope
i don't know i'm hoping against hope
that everybody can set aside their
religion their political differences
their boundaries their their country
lines
their nuclear weapons and all of that
[ __ ] we can start maybe together trying
to uh live in a cleaner world so we
don't all [ __ ] die a thirst here
jesus christ how much [ __ ] harder
does it have to get it's unbelievable
unfucking believable um
and then somebody sent me this thing
on the instagram there so you know it's
got to be true
showing how the government has all like
these underground [ __ ] caves and [ __ ]
with years and years and years of
supplies of food and all of that [ __ ]
i just remember seeing that going like
that's just that unsettling [ __ ] where
they're like they're really not they
have no answers to our problems
and one day
they're gonna be like just you know uh
tighten the belts at a thousand points
of light
and enough is enough i am the greatest
president ever and they're just going to
be doing that and then they got to go
good night mr mrs america good night
everybody in the world and then when
they sign off they're going to be like
all right let's go and they're all just
going to go underground and that's going
to be it and then the next day there's
just going to be nobody on washington
military nobody higher ranking is going
to be [ __ ]
available
and they're all going to be underground
making sandwiches
and every once in a while they'll just
hear a bunch of screaming and [ __ ] you
know
when they're dirt sailing whatever the
[ __ ] is going on at the end of the world
they're just gonna stay down there
it actually makes me think man
that's that's a good reason to join
either the military or the government
and try to just work your way up the
security clearance
clearances you know
so when that giant [ __ ] vault door to
underground closes they're letting you
in
all right this way mr johnson the corn
flakes are on the right the uh powdered
water is on the left we have the [ __ ]
in the lower layer
uh flat screen tv we've recorded
everything netflix has ever posted uh in
your lifetime you won't be able to watch
all of it so you'll be
entertained uh we're gonna do the men in
black things so you forget all sports
you've ever watched it's gonna be great
it's gonna be just like living up there
except you're gonna be down here that's
all we have vitamin d
everything you could possibly need and
uh we have uh robot prostitutes
and all the gold and all of that [ __ ]
and uh everybody else upstairs above the
ground uh
[ __ ] em
i think that that's what's gonna happen
i think that's the solution
um
and the only person to blame is god
it's god's fault okay i'm sick of him
dishing it off to the devil it's now
dude you made all of these psychos you
did
you did and they've led us to this
all right
which is fine
i get it it's like he wrote a script
there's a beginning middle and an end
all right this is getting dark
um i actually watched a couple of really
uh
amazing uh french one documentary and
one movie
all right i'm gonna go with the first
one
there's this movie called the wolf's
call
le chad de la rue or whatever the [ __ ]
they could say in french
um
something like that
uh the wolf's call and it has one of my
favorite french actors i hope i say his
name right it's redder
i english way you'd say kteb i'm sure
i'm not saying it right
um he was in that great prison movie a
prophet 2009 you got to check that one
out
it's [ __ ] incredible and uh but this
was a
a military drama about nuclear
submarines and um
it's uh
just was done top [ __ ] notch
and uh the twists and turns because
they've done like this story has been
told before
about a nuclear standoff and all that
just the way they did it and the way
they shot it and the acting was just
[ __ ] amazing it was really really
amazing i highly recommend it if you
don't mind reading subtitles
uh but the acting in it and the
directing the cinematography and all
that is just crazy called the wolf's
call it's on netflix and then i saw
another one
it was a documentary
called uh wonder boy
it's about this french designer olivier
rousting and i'm sure i'm saying it
wrong
because believe it or not i am not that
much in the um
fashion world you wouldn't know it to
look at me
you know to see you know my malcolm
young
jeans and t-shirt
style that i have still look like i'm
unloading trucks in a warehouse
um
i didn't know anything about it which is
why i watch it that's what i do on
netflix because i try to watch the most
random [ __ ]
i can possibly watch that's good
so i can get a better
mix of [ __ ]
in my queue or whatever they call it
that's why you know you watch a little
one punch man little japanese anime
you watch a french
documentary you're all over the map
you know
because i told you a long time ago i
watched one of the i watched two seasons
of narcos and then every [ __ ] thing
on my front page was behind the scenes
san quentin
aryan prisoners the rules they live by
behind the walls
you know and they have all those guys
you know
speaking with their voices altered and
their face all blurred out
you know when i was behind bars one of
the roof was it was [ __ ]
we called me stabilizers
so you're saying you'd sharpen your
toothbrush and you could make that into
a weapon that is what i'm saying [ __ ]
um it's like you know i don't want to
watch that all the [ __ ] time right so
um
so this wonder boy thing is really
fascinating and uh
it made me think about a lot of [ __ ]
when i was watching he's
basically incredibly successful
person
uh
great looking dude like he like he was
sitting there with all the supermodels
and when he was in the photos he was as
good-looking as they were he looked like
like one of the models but he was the
guy who actually was designing all of
the stuff
and uh
he's adopted and the
the story is him trying to find his
birth parents
and his feelings about despite growing
up in this house where he felt like you
know obviously you could see like his
adopted parents loved him his
grandparents were unbelievable
um all this love but just not knowing
like who he was
you know because of his skin color he
thought maybe he was half white half
black he was looking at his facial
features and he just had to guess he
just wanted to [ __ ] know right
so um
and the the director i know i'm going to
say her name wrong anissa
bonaphong i don't know how to say it but
was amazing the way they told the story
the way they put it together
it's really beautifully uh
shot and everything
and um
i mean i guess
i don't know they got 23 and me now but
i always feel like they're just doing
that so they can make the [ __ ] robot
replacement of you
but i remember uh you know growing up
you know when roots came out and stuff
like that and and black people saying
like what it felt like to just not know
where you were from have no history none
of that type of stuff like how that like
you know it's like if you whenever i
move even if i go to a new city i want
to read up on the history of it so i can
somehow feel rooted in it just as a
person to not know where you're from and
who your parents are
and all of that type of stuff and maybe
think about all of that like slavery how
you did that to an entire race of people
just how crazy like all of that is in
this kid's story
um
you know
i don't know just not having grown up
like that i would have thought that you
know if you got put up for adoption but
you had the awesome parents and
grandparents that he had
that
that could take the place of it and i
saw that it didn't mean it's and and he
you know he finds out about you know
stuff about his parents and stuff
that obviously blows his mind and
everything like that i don't ruin it but
you should definitely check it out it's
called wonderboy
on netflix look at me oh cultured bill
watching a couple of french movies i'm
telling you i'm going to get that
someday
one or two things going to happen i'm
going to be able to play good times bad
times every time i get close i get busy
and i got to [ __ ] go back down to 80
85 bpms god damn it
um
or i'm gonna become fluent in french or
maybe i'll do both
i don't know anyway uh
so i've been doing good i've been uh
working out and everything i'm getting
ready for fenway oh billy uh billy's
getting the [ __ ] his revenge body
back
and uh i'm knocking this podcast out
here on a sunday afternoon
basket tomorrow i have a uh
i have a uh i have a procedure
you know i have a medical procedure that
needs to be done tomorrow now whenever a
man of a certain age
doesn't say exactly like i'm getting a
hip replacement or i'm getting some hair
plugs if they just say they're getting a
procedure
that means one thing and one thing only
there's something going on with this ash
[Music]
[Laughter]
ah getting the old colonoscopy everybody
the old [ __ ] jacques cousteau up the
[ __ ] yeah that's what's happening
tomorrow so
yeah that was medicine you got a [ __ ]
drink to
clean yourself out and be [ __ ]
jeff daniels and dumber dumber for the
next [ __ ] six hours
not to get it too gross here so that's
what's going on with me tomorrow so uh
yeah that is it and uh baseball we're
we're gonna plow right through that what
i was just talking about baseball who do
we got here we we're we're at the
all-star break
and uh
my red sox playing the yankees today
we've we won the first game got smoked
the second game but you know we've taken
three of the last four from them gone
three and three
the last six games you know
although they kind of red sox made a
statement that this is a rebuilding year
that kind of sucked that [ __ ] devil
race series just took everything out of
us
um but i know they're gonna show up at
least against the yankees then it's the
all-star break and guess what the
all-star game's out here baby
at georgia stadium
all-star game is at dodger stadium and
uh i'm gonna go to it it's the last
all-star game in professional sports i
need to go to i went to the pro bowl out
in hawaii
the all-star game nhl all-star game was
out here in 2017 and uh i think two
thousand
maybe
i went to the nba all-star game [ __ ] was
it that long ago remember doc rivers was
still
was coaching the uh the all-star team so
we must have won it the year before in
uh so yeah this is the last one so i'm
looking forward to that
it's a cool thing to go to because you
end up seeing a bunch of hall of famers
is the [ __ ] ac not working here
[ __ ] goddamn house you buy there's
always some sort of a [ __ ] problem
oh no
oh no what is the deal here
of course
of course hottest [ __ ] day of the
year in the ac breaks yeah i didn't see
that coming
didn't see that coming oh yeah do you
have a pool oh yeah
great day to go swimming ah deer took a
[ __ ] in it yeah i can't get to it to
monday
you know that day you can't go swimming
because you're having a medical
procedure
yeah then you can go swimming on that
[ __ ] day god damn it
maybe it's just the batteries in the uh
in the thing but i [ __ ] turned it on
whatever
[Music]
the [ __ ] you gonna do
um
so i want to thank everybody too who
sent uh
who sent in all that that [ __ ] music
jesus christ like i gotta be honest with
you guys i can't keep up with a lot of
that [ __ ] i was talking about how i like
that new porcupine tree album and i
think i'm actually
you know of course they're [ __ ]
playing out here in la
you know
and uh i'm on the road i get i get back
like two days
after that so i'm thinking well maybe
they'll go down to san diego and i'm
seeing them there but like the next day
they're in mexico city
but uh
one of my road dates crisscrosses with
uh
their tour
they play the same city i do the day
after i'm there so i'm gonna go to the
show then
um so that should be fun
and uh but uh let me see because i
downloaded some of this [ __ ] you guys
told me to download but good lord
it's just too much for my ears to try to
like
to take in
well i downloaded it didn't come on i
had the worst [ __ ] wi-fi
all of that whatever the hell it was
like death
um there was another beginning with c or
something like that all of these these
[ __ ]
uh
like me sugar level bands like that is
just a lot it just just
try and listen to it and even remotely
figure out what is going on musically
especially with the drums the way it was
mixed my ears just aren't good enough at
this point so i i need to like ease my
way into that [ __ ] i think as far as
like you know
progressive metal which i don't even
know what i think you know what it is i
just like [ __ ] that's in different time
signatures um so i think i'm gonna stick
porcupine tree you know obviously tulle
that type of stuff
and i think gradually i'll keep
listening to meshuggah and that type of
stuff and then i think it won't seem so
foreign
to my brain because i know it's
incredible music and musicianship is
insane i just
you know i always equate it to like i
saw tony williams the great tony
williams play live and i knew what he
was doing was amazing but i didn't know
why
i just knew it sounded really complex
and complicated but i didn't know what
the [ __ ] was going on and when everybody
else clapped i clapped too
but you know
i mean i yeah i could barely keep time
when i listen to the guy play so when
he's doing all that polyrhythm [ __ ] like
i didn't know what was going on i just
knew
that he
was one of the great drummers and all
the drummers i liked talked about how
awesome he was so i went to go see him
so
god damn [ __ ] ac good lord if it's
not something it's [ __ ] something
else is that how it goes it's not one
thing the a it's not one thing it's the
other
all right
um
thank you to everybody who came out to
the shows
in um
in las vegas
we had a uh i went out there with
bartnik who dude i'm telling you he's
never been funnier absolutely [ __ ]
murdered both shows
uh so happy for him we're editing his uh
his special right now me and ben tishla
and uh actually ben's been doing it with
joe and uh
we'll be having that thing coming out at
some point by the end of the year it
should be awesome
so uh i didn't really do anything man i
just [ __ ] hung out we just went back
to the room
chilled out
you know my wife would come back with
his sister they had a great time at the
show and we would all just hang out
order some food or whatever
but um so that's it so my next big gig
coming up is i have uh
what do i got i got montreal a montreal
forum whatever the [ __ ] the molson
center uh the [ __ ] uh
the timmy horton [ __ ]
hoedown whatever the hell they call
their place up there i got that thing
coming up so looking forward to that
um you know montreal is a beautiful
beautiful city
and uh i can't wait this is another way
for me to practice my french with those
fake french people
you know
because i know that like real french
people laugh at people
french canadians like the way they
pronounce their words
that they're not speaking real french
which is just [ __ ] hilarious to me
like
it's like yes they are they're just
somewhere else so the accent is a little
different
stop being so [ __ ] precious oh
you know what my dream is my dream is to
be able to be totally fluent in french
go to paris do a show in french and just
trash them
you know and just be speaking beautiful
french
as an american
in shape who traveled speaking another
language destroying all of their
stereotypes about americans and then
making fun of them with their pocket
squares
you know and their hoity-toity [ __ ]
attitudes in their accents when they try
to [ __ ] speak english
um
that's what always has amazed me about
the french where it's like literally
they get offended when you're like
butchering their language and then they
turn around and speak english to you and
start butchering your language and
you're supposed to be like all right i
guess it's okay when you do it to me
so anyway um
yeah looking forward to the uh
the all-star game
and whatever and uh oh i don't know if i
mentioned this i i did i mentioned the
last podcast yeah i took my first
passenger up and the helicopter took
dean del rey up
and uh
it was
kind of anti-climactic
um
i knew what i was doing in a good way
like i was totally comfortable i wasn't
nervous i was definitely think you know
getting ready if anything happened i
knew i knew what i was doing and all of
that [ __ ] and we would be fine but i was
also making sure i knew which way the
wind was going where i would put it down
like at all times
of course it was a [ __ ] hazy day
uh it was just this haze hanging over so
i didn't go out over malibu and
everything because i figured it would be
uh i don't know
it just said six statute miles
visibility and i was just like yeah
i don't need to be [ __ ] flying in
that i'll if it's 10 that's when i go
and then of course the next day when i
wasn't flying and the day before i flew
it was just an absolute perfect day and
that's kind of like uh how it works i
think my next solo flight i'm going to
do i'm going to go out to this airport
victorville
i've gone out there one other time with
an instructor it's a really nice flight
and uh
you're on the other side of the san
gabriel mountains and there's really
nothing out there once you get past like
agua dulce and all of that
which is great nice flat land if you
have a problem there's nobody my only
thing i would worry about is if i had to
do an auto rotation out there and i
landed whose property i land on and if
they [ __ ] tweaking out there and
think i'm the feds
i might have a problem but other than
that it's a pretty safe place to fly out
there and out in victorville they have
like this
all of these planes
like jumbo jet aircraft that have timed
out
and they're just
sitting out there
um it's pretty wild like i don't
quite understand
how all of that works and what you do
with those things but
you know i used to watch like gas monkey
garage
and i'm thinking is there like the
airplane version of this
you just
pull up in a raptor with the [ __ ]
trailer and tow a [ __ ] old dc-10
decommissioned dc10 out of there and
we're gonna lower it gonna put some big
brakes on it
make it all electric i mean that's
something for like technology you know
they know how to do it but there's
everybody's trying to protect their
position in the market and
blaming their shareholders and all of
that [ __ ] can somebody in the business
world explain to me what that means
whenever they do these diabolical moves
they always say we have to keep our
shareholders
happy now i own shares i'm in the stock
market no one has ever asked me whether
i'm happy i don't know who the [ __ ] to
complain to isn't that really the people
on the board of directors who sit on a
corporation and even when the
corporation
loses money or nosedives they still
somehow cut themselves a check for like
200 300 million dollars for all their
incredible work making the business
[ __ ] fail
um
i don't know i have no idea so
let's do some advertising here uh
because i gotta go uh
play with my kids oh my god it was
awesome when i came home
they were both freaking out and uh my
daughter's getting a little bit older
though i kind of noticed so you know
she's definitely psyched to hugs me but
now she has this little ipad where she
watches her educational shows
plus that kid ryan she watches that [ __ ]
all the time so we've been getting her
to watch less of that
um it's a really difficult parenting
point
those [ __ ] things because if you just
don't if they're not around them at all
they're not gonna know how to use them
and then they go out into the world and
they can be like what is that so they
got to be able to interact with them
but you don't want them to be like these
zombies
um
but my son of course the second i come
home he's like daddy's truck daddy's
truck dad is truck you know wants to
take a ride in the truck
just out of the garage uh so i gotta go
do that
before the proverbial [ __ ] storm
that my life's gonna be uh over the next
[ __ ] 12 hours here um all right
anything else
i think that's it all right let's uh
let's do a little bit of advertising
here
oh my god the [ __ ] ac jesus christ
all right look who's here everybody it's
all
zip
zip recruiter everybody uh you know i'm
excited to travel this summer
evidently according to the coffee have
you ever thought about all of the people
that you make
that make a vacation truly great
talk about people who make a great trip
possible especially those that you
appreciate oh i'll tell you i'll tell
you who club soda kenny
club soda kenny meets me at the airport
club soda kenny gets me into the car
club soda kenny checks me into the hotel
i don't have to [ __ ] think about
anything
club soda kenny
okay my name's bill burr and i support
this message example hotel concierge who
knows the best places to go oh
absolutely
tour guys with great stories you know
speaking of that
i was talking to one of the security
people at the cosmo
and this guy was a
former new york city police officer so
me being a car guy i was like what years
he told me what years and i was just
like oh okay early 80s did you what was
that what'd you guys have like the
chrysler new yorkers he goes yeah we had
that we had the chryslers with the two
gumballs on top he goes then we moved to
the k cars which sucked they were too
small then i think they went chevy and
then ford
i think they had the uh
either the caprices or the impalas
or then they had the um
then they went to the crown vix i'm not
sure but he told me these
you know he got me reading up on the
crown crown heights riots of the early
90s
it's an absolutely
heartbreaking story that ended up
leading to more violence and all of that
type of [ __ ] uh i was a race riot and
all of this
type of [ __ ] and i was like was that
white's first blacks he was like no it
was acidic jews
and and black people going out and he
goes we were the referees
i was like you were there he goes i was
there
so he told me some great stories um
but anyways this is a zip recruiter ad
um
anyway you know outstanding talent is
crucial for success a successful
business and if you're hiring uh you you
can find talent for roles like these and
more at zip
uh when you try for free at
ziprecruiter.com zippercura uses its
powerful technology to find and match
the right candidates up with your job
you can easily review these recommended
candidates and invite your top choices
to apply your top choices
four to five employers who post on zip
yes yes
get a quality candidate within the first
day no wonder zip
[Music]
is the number one rated hiring site
based on
g2 satisfaction ratings as of january
1st 2022 so travel
so travel to this easy to remember
website ziprecruiter.com
that's where you can try ziprecruiter
for free again that's ziprecruited.com
slash burr spell out bird b-u-r-r zip
yeah
the smartest way to hire
all right i guess we're already into the
letters everybody
we're already into the letters this week
uh somebody writes in says thank you
well isn't that nice you know that's
that's really a word that i feel is
underused in the english language
just to thank you
you know or a sarcastic one
i like an i like nice nice is a great
sarcastic one
you know somebody cut you off in traffic
nice nice
nice move
you start clapping
great job buddy no no no hey look it's
your world buddy i'm just [ __ ]
driving in it you [ __ ] big headed
[ __ ]
um
all right thank you mr burr i am a huge
fan of your stand up and efforts for
family oh well thank you for watching
that still exists
on netflix everybody um
i'm a disabled us marine with two tours
to iraq
i suffer from ptsd anxiety and
depression along with two bad knees oh
man uh
have you have you looked uh up on any of
this stuff like those
guided trips where you use psychedelics
that's like becoming the thing
there's this whole thing on netflix
about this [ __ ] guy who looks like
he's 100 years old
like snorting tobacco
like if you're smoking it's bad for you
but if you snort it he goes
he's out there with this shaman or
whatever or shy woman i don't know what
and he [ __ ] snorts tobacco and he's
like oh he's like my head feels like
it's on fire
now it's moving down through my body
um
i find it weird that they have all these
old things that people used to do and
these are evidently better than what
they have at a cvs
yet people live longer now i don't know
what that is maybe because you kind of
lived outside even if you were inside
back then
as i [ __ ] about my [ __ ] air
conditioning um
anyway he says as you may or she says he
or she
says uh as you may guess yes i was
infantry
that's the real deal right there uh your
special and show helped me laugh and
makes my day a little better that's good
to hear not only that but the practical
wisdom you give i agree not that you
care
uh i totally care if you're
complimenting me with my [ __ ] ego uh
i agree with not that you care with most
of the stuff you say because i'm feeling
like a grumpy man and it's nice to hear
someone sees things
as i
and i don't feel so alone thank you for
your honesty and your com uh comedy
yours
and then he leaves his name but i try
not to use names here because god knows
someone will try to [ __ ]
use this [ __ ] against this person so
well thank you very much u.s marine
corps look at that
look at that the
marines okay not not those fly boys in
the [ __ ] air force
walking around like tom cruise actually
wasn't tom cruise in the navy
wait a minute he's an actor sorry
um i just got caught up and you know i
never saw the top gun i got it the top
gun that's how old i am have you seen
the top gun is it on the internet
yet um
i gotta see that uh
yeah well you know something uh
forget about
watching efforts for family and all of
that stuff um
i'm gonna look this up for you
there's something you can check out and
there's all of these these
new things like this this is you know
what it is is i think everybody knows
that these psychedelic things are
actually they're onto something with
ptsd how much it's like helping
so the pharmacies have to gain control
of them and come up with their synthetic
versions that won't be as good as the
other ones so they can corner the
[ __ ] you know the usual [ __ ] all
right netflix
series
[Music]
oh god psychedelics
psych uh
oh i kind of got it
i went with the a instead of the e
um psychedelics
oh what the [ __ ] is it
oh how to change your mind
but there's a number of of things
on it
there's something called the mind
explained
i mean jesus christ that's a little
[ __ ] arrogant oh did you figure it
out
um how to change your mind check that
out you know at the very least if you
get nothing out of it it's funny to
watch a 60 year old guy snort tobacco
it's a burning sensation
looks like the [ __ ] [ __ ] keeper
um it's funny because he's saying how
good and how much it helps him but he
does not look healthy whatsoever i'm
just being honest
so uh check that out
if uh if you get a chance um all right
red rocks
special let the red rock
special shine a lot on you
uh hey bill we are coming to see you in
buffalo i haven't been in buffalo in
forever on august 26th
still i still cannot believe i never
took the time
to just get on the mass pike drive west
and go see the bruins play the sabers in
the odd i never did it
um
i gotta tell you they always lament
about those old [ __ ] uh is that the
right word the uh the old baseball
stadiums
you know the brooklyn dodgers how sad
they were when they tore those things
down i got to tell you some of those old
hockey ones
you know maple leaf gardens
uh the original montreal forum the
olympia where the red wings played
chicago stadium
um
the boston garden the odd
i did see the [ __ ] islanders nassau
coliseum versus the rages
like the spri uh
end of the winter spring like around
march february or march of 1989
i went to a game out there and it was
[ __ ] mayhem
um
it was actually really scary because
that's back when like traveling was
traveling like he didn't there wasn't
you know there was no internet
um
i mean i know al gore was [ __ ]
working on it
he was working on it working on an
inconvenient truth
um
so when you traveled back then it was
before like corporations totally took
over when you when you
like i used to visit family out in the
midwest and you went out there and even
like the road looked different they had
a lot more concrete on their road they
had bob's big boys they still had chains
but they had different chains and like
one of those never went there and they
had the malted milks
and uh the signage looked a little bit
different the accents everything was
like different um
so when i went down to that game the
rangers versus the islanders in nassau
coliseum i just remembered like hearing
these [ __ ] crazy accents like
everybody sounded like they were in the
[ __ ] ramones
and they were just beating the sh there
was a couple fights beating the [ __ ] out
of each other like guys way too old to
be getting into fights
people with like [ __ ] on like full-on
[ __ ] or [ __ ] on that's full-on
abbreviation if you're learning the
language full-on
um
like mustaches
and loafers if you can grow facial hair
and you're wearing loafers you should be
not you're too old to be into a fight
i just remember this guy that was when
they had like those cheap loafers with
the gold
[ __ ] thing on the front
to show that you were successful i just
remember this guy like trying to lay
across he was like laying across three
people trying to throw an uppercut with
like no momentum whatsoever
and i was just sitting there keeping my
mouth shut because it's like uh
i'm just sort of a sports fan and uh i
can't believe i'm here right now
because it was 1989 and the islanders
had won four in a row from 80 to 83 so
there was only you know six years
removed from that so it was still like
i'm thinking you know billy smith mike
bossie and all of those guys mike bossy
rest his soul
and um
i don't know
so now when i look back i was just like
why didn't i just [ __ ] get in my
piece of [ __ ] truck and drive all over
drive down to hartford to see the
whalers
or go up to go see the nordiques that'd
be a [ __ ] plane ride though um i did
see the canadians in the old forum all
right bill let's get back to buffalo um
will the buffalo show
uh be different material than what is on
the redrock special
we want to watch it but not if it's the
same stuff dude why the [ __ ] would i do
that i would never do that to you
the special once i shoot a special i'm
immediately
dumping all of that material and by the
time the special comes out you know
seven eight months later i have my new
hour it's up and running
and i won't feel like i'm just i would
never do that because you'd be like well
what the [ __ ]
you just did the same [ __ ] and i spent
all of this money i could have just
stayed home and then the next time i go
to buffalo you're not gonna go see me so
i would never do that to myself because
then i would gradually lose my following
and i have to get a real job
which is not what i want to do
all right here we go millennials are to
blame for inflation oh jesus hey billy
on the nose
did you see the cnbc article with the
headline stating that millennials are to
blame for inflation
no i didn't but what little i know about
the economy that makes in the the
federal reserve that makes no sense
whatsoever unless everyone in the
federal reserve is a millennial
but it was already evil before they got
there so they're just towing the company
line right he said they eventually had
to change the headline because it got
roasted hard by people pointing out that
half the money supply was printed in the
last few years yeah
nothing will cause inflation
like uh printing more money and it took
me the longest time
to figure this out so i'll try to
explain it in layman's terms and i'll
probably [ __ ] this up
because it's been a while since i read
up on it but basically
money
you know back in the day had value
because it represented
something of value being gold
so back in the day
when you had gold it was very dangerous
to have it if you traveled with it
people would rob you
and blah blah so then they came up with
banks
right
take your money you keep it
here uh
for safety so you give them just to make
things easy you gave them
a hundred dollars worth of gold and then
they gave you a hundred dollars in cash
and what those
bills used to say that it was redeemable
for the value of the piece of paper in
gold and you could go into the bank and
get your [ __ ] gold back it was one of
the great robberies of all time
and eventually they took us off the gold
standard and they kept everybody's gold
and they just kept giving out the paper
and what happened was
is your money has value
if there's gold behind it
and um
how do i do this let's just say you had
a hundred million in gold
and you had a hundred million in cash
then
one dollar
is worth it's worth the 100 million
dollars is worth 100 million dollars
right
it's worth that pile of gold right now
if you just go print another 100 million
dollars you just made the value of the
dollar is now cut in half
because all of that money is you didn't
get any more gold you just printed more
money so the more money you're printing
versus that [ __ ] gold
the less each piece of paper is worth
because all of that paper still
represents the same amount of gold
so now you have 300 million dollars but
you only have 100 million dollars worth
of gold because you didn't get any more
[ __ ] gold so now that dollar is worth
like
33.3 cents
and what i don't understand is why they
don't just keep
price is the same
like how do they know that they [ __ ]
printed more like how do how do
businesses know that they printed more
money
i don't get how that aspect of it works
but it seems
you know the whole thing is a [ __ ]
ponzi scheme and at some point i believe
around richard nixon
they just worked on democrat and
republicans both sides i'm not blame
either but i think nixon was the guy who
just finally took us 100 off the gold
standard
um
woodrow wilson was the guy that signed
off on the federal reserve that made it
a private corporation federal reserve is
a private corporation of bankers there's
the joke is uh it is as federal as
federal express
and they're a private group of bankers
they're not connected to the government
that's why the president always has to
guess what the fed's gonna do because he
has no power or control over them
they control us
uh they are the the official bernie
madoffs
of this country and uh i don't know
how to undo it or whatever i felt like
bernie sanders had some good ideas and
you know somebody has some good ideas
to put bankers in their place when
they're called a socialist or a
communist those are the buzzwords
if somebody's called a socialist or a
communist it means they're trying to
help out regular people
and uh
everybody gets on both sides gets afraid
of that word and there's just too many
[ __ ] people
that get elected on both sides that
aren't going to do the [ __ ] right
thing and the banks continue to go so i
probably didn't explain it
correctly so you can't blame millennials
for inflation because they didn't go out
and print a whole bunch of money while
not finding more gold to back it
um so i guess now the only thing that
gives our dollar
value is the fact that the world's oil
supply is still measured
against u.s dollars
and i believe
i'm dusting this [ __ ] off i believe that
saddam hussein was trying to get
together with hugo chavez
both major oil suppliers
to start
he was going to start
putting his stuff out
euros per barrel which who gives him the
authority to do that who gives us the
authority that we were doing it i don't
know
but that was allegedly what he was going
to do because he was trying to bankrupt
the u.s
so he could get out from us babysitting
us
babysitting him
so and then that's when we came up with
the hey he had something to do with 911
so we could get [ __ ] rid of that guy
and get our own guy in there that's what
the conspiracy theory is
about all of that [ __ ] so
um
but all of these problems are just
[ __ ] how do you how do you even
think of this stuff how do you even get
your head around it like why you would
do that to
to people is is beyond me like why you
would
take their gold and say we're gonna keep
it safe and then just take it for
yourself like
the [ __ ] is wrong with you
[Laughter]
i just don't understand
why people would do that um anyway on
anything better
you mentioned
how you used to complain about the world
banks and how you got nowhere but i'm
here to say you turned me and my friends
onto a lot of the stuff we care about
today
keep that rosy chin up and don't ever
sell yourself short all the ranting you
did help spark others into learning
about the real enemies of the world
mission accomplished colonel ruby roids
yeah but they're still in power
they're still in power and they have
underground caves and [ __ ] that's why
you know i just try to live a small life
now i i what are you gonna do
um i don't know what their end game is
but they're not gonna win
by crushing everybody underneath them at
the very least they're going to have to
do their own landscaping and fix their
own air conditioners if they get rid of
all of us regular people right
are you saying people that landscape and
fix air conditioners are air quote
regular
yes i am
um environmentalist here oh jesus
you know there's an environmental uh
list book that i wanted to read that
this female scientist wrote
back in the days called this uh silent
spring
and it was predicting everything that
was basically happening today with with
pesticides and all of that um
we're back in the day you know
if bugs and all of that [ __ ] got to
crops all of a sudden there was like no
strawberries that year if there was a
frost or something like that whatever
the hell it was i think it was more like
insects
so they came up these pesticides which
in the short run were
fantastic and in the long run you know
just poisoned animals and all of this it
just
it's unreal
it's unreal if we would just let
ourselves die naturally
instead of fighting our environment
what we're doing with the environment i
think is remember the great thing about
breaking bad was every move that mr
white did to try to get out just sort of
tighten the noose around his neck a
little more
it just created an even bigger problem
and i feel like that's what we're doing
right this is getting too dark sorry
environmentalist here uh hey billy
two-tooth
um i work for a wildlife group and
consult with an energy company i want to
thank you for pointing out the biggest
problem plaguing the earth it's not
fossil fuels it's not the lack of
electric cars it's the production of
useless goods
governments and companies are trying to
blame commoners like us even though we
have much less of an effect
on things than them the the militaries
of the world namely
the u.s are the largest polluters on the
planet yet their budgets grow by 15
year
uh
year over year
i think you mean year after year uh
you're the only one i've heard in the
mainstream that constantly points out
the waste product made by consumers yeah
we've made so many advancements in fuel
extractions and efficiencies yet no one
talks about the consumer waste and trash
piles absolutely all you have to do is
look at hoarders
you know i just do a joke in my act how
i like tortors
you know there's an honesty the way they
live they're just sitting there like
this is this is what i did this is the
mess i made of my life as opposed to
those [ __ ] minimalists who throw all
their [ __ ] out
and then act like they're a genius
because they got two pairs of pants
uh i'm not saying oil spills aren't a
problem i'm just saying that if we stop
consuming goods at the rate that we do
we wouldn't have as many oil-based
plastics disturbing the natural order of
the earth
thanks for being a unique thinker in a
world of drones and sheep who think
putting a tree
in their twitter bio means they're part
of the solution yeah but i and i also
think if we went like uh
you know nuclear and electric
it would get us out of the middle east
and then we wouldn't have to worry about
you know all of these nuclear programs
that they're allegedly having that we
for some reason can't find
um
yeah they wouldn't have the money to do
it
you could stay home but we don't want to
do that we want to be over there and
suck all their [ __ ] rece you know we
don't
all right
i don't want to do that but [ __ ]
esso and all those other [ __ ] i
named the canadian one just for the hell
of it um
i don't know what the [ __ ] do i know uh
my family loves reminding me that i'm
broke jesus christ
dear billy basketball ref i'm a 25 year
old man
in my last year at university i work
full time late night six days a week at
a mutual labor job because i can't work
a nine to five office job with school
i've been making the [ __ ] money at a
[ __ ] job for my entire adult life
because i bought into this idea of
grinding hard until i one day graduate
and get a cushy job and can find
finally afford a home and a life first
of all you're only 25.
you're talking like you're [ __ ] 55.
uh my family only checks in on me once
in a while to remind me that i'm poor
my sister just texted me to show off her
new gold-plated diamond-encrusted shiny
white
land rover from the future that she got
for her birthday and from her husband
because the audi suv wasn't enough and
it was starting to get old that was in
quotes
i drive a clapped out jetta
i don't know what clapped out means but
with the these description that means
you're driving a [ __ ] box uh with busted
headlights in a cracked bumper because i
can't afford to fix it my big birthday
gift is two tickets i bought myself to
go see some stand up with a friend my
sister didn't even go to college just
she just married a guy with money and i
feel like she has no idea how hard i
work to just get by on my lower class
lifestyle
um as you may know rent is going crazy
lately and i was priced out of my one
bedroom apartment and forced to move
into an old house on the outskirts of
town with some work friends my parents
heard about my move and rather than
supporting my hard decision to relocate
all they wanted to tell me was how i
chose a bad neighborhood like i'm in
some idiot
like as if i'm choosing to live in the
ghetto and i don't know any better i
lived in this city all through college
i'm keenly aware of what i can't afford
and where
i'm not saying my family owns owes me
anything but [ __ ]
is at least a little moral support too
much to ask um
sometimes it is
you know just because they're your
family doesn't mean they're cool
and that's one of the weirdest things
when you have to cut out people that are
actually in your family
um you can't always 100 do it because
you are related to them or whatever but
like uh
you know
maybe you can just put your sister on
mute a little bit
anyway maybe don't rub it in when you
buy a six-figure suv with the seat
warmers and dick massagers i don't know
i know if anyone knows the feeling of
being broke it's a career comedian
so as to someone who i'm sure has been
there before how do you respond to these
family members
uh you don't
you don't you don't uh
if you truly think
um
that your sister's doing that to rubbing
it in your face to rub it in your face
um and she's not just clueless or
whatever
um
then you know that's just something you
have to like deal with that's a really
weird thing
when there's a sibling or a parent or
something like that
that is in your life
that you know
you know the deal where i feel like you
know if you weren't related to me that i
would have cut you out of my life 20
years ago you know that [ __ ]
situation that's a tough thing to be in
um because everyone's like oh you got to
hang in there because they're going to
die someday and you're going to regret
it it's just like what am i missing out
on
what you really regret is that your
sister isn't loving and caring
or understanding
[Laughter]
or your parents are but there's nothing
you can do about it anyways
he says uh how do i go home from my job
at 2am and not feel like an absolute
loser night after night knowing no one
else in my circle had to do any of this
uh quote act like you've been there
before thanks for all the awesome free
content and all the laughs
hope you come to my state soon love the
red rock special by the way thank you um
i don't know you know what
i can't tell you i haven't gone through
years like that
like i remember when i was driving a
[ __ ] box and
rather than trading it in i just
had a guy put a new engine in on it in
the thing and i just remember the woman
that i work with
like didn't even understand it because
they all had like car notes and stuff
and i knew i wanted to be a comedian i
had to keep my expenses down
and i told her she goes so you're gonna
get a new car i said you know what i go
i i decided to put a new engine in my
truck instead
she just made this face and just goes
that was stupid
[Laughter]
i remember being annoyed and then aft
you know years later thinking back going
like it wasn't
it wasn't because back then i did this
in like the 90s i mean the guy even
[ __ ] me over and it only cost me
like a couple of grand as opposed to
buying a new car at the time
which even like a [ __ ] one
was like 12 grand
so i mean it was a way smarter move and
then also what i liked was my truck was
starting to rust out so i had this new
engine in it so i could park it anywhere
and nobody [ __ ] knew that i had this
brand new [ __ ] engine
in it so sort of a sleeper
um
so what i would do with your sister oh
that's awesome congratulations on your
land rover and just stop expecting her
to understand what it is that you're
going through and don't expect your
parents
you just i would just go humor
you know like when your parents are like
well that's a bad neighborhood
and just be like yeah i know i like
living on the edge
it's how i am you know i'm a risk taker
um
and then i would just
block them out and i would just continue
doing what it is that you're doing so
um i think you do it sounds like you
need some sort of direction because if
your end result is you just want to get
a cushy job where you're making money
um
i'm just speaking myself personally that
i find a cushy job where i was making a
bunch of [ __ ] money that i didn't
love eventually
i would be bored shitless
so i would try to find
a job that you love
where you can make enough money to live
your life and like
look you know i would be honest with you
i would just
keep doing what you're doing
you don't need people like that in your
life in your day to
day uh they're family so you have to
tolerate them and i would just
concentrate on trying to find a person
to share your life with that you truly
love
and that isn't like those people but you
re maybe if you had time talk to
somebody too so you don't repeat it
and marry somebody like your mom or your
sister if they're the way you're saying
it they are you know
i don't know
it's a lot of [ __ ] buddy it's a lot of
stuff you're going through i have
empathy for you but you're only 25 years
old
i mean when i was 25 i was still living
at home with a [ __ ] rusted out car
with the new engine in it
driving to the second to last exit on
the mass pike
but no money i didn't think i had those
gigs yet
i was doing open mics i had five minutes
of material and i won this comedy
competition called the wbcn comedy riot
i won the last year that they had it
in 1993
at old the old stitches comedy club and
uh that's where i was at and i still
didn't get
really any paid work
until the next year in 94
and uh
yeah that's i don't know i just started
making some money in comedy i was making
money at my day job i could have quit my
day job i didn't i kept working there
and i would do shows at night and i just
started banking the money and paying off
all my credit cards and my [ __ ]
student loans
so when i moved down to new york i had
like a nest egg or whatever and uh
ended up trying to change the
fuel filter
and i got impatient
and uh i snapped it off and i brought it
over to this guy and i told him what i
did and he wasn't really listening
and i actually had the fuel filter
snapped off in the driver's seat and one
of his
other mechanics went in to start it up
and gas went over the engine had a giant
[ __ ] electrical fire
and i remember he [ __ ] yelled at me
and i'm like dude i told you what
happened
he's like i'm so [ __ ] sick of you
guys trying to do the job and you [ __ ]
it up and then you bring it down admit
dell this type of [ __ ]
and i went down there i remember um
he tried to say there was no charge and
i said no i'm gonna pay for it and he
gave me that sly look cause
my dad told me he said make sure you pay
for it so there's a record that you were
down there he doesn't want you to pay
for it
and uh and i never [ __ ]
you know i never charged them and i
didn't have the money to get the
electrical fixed and i kept [ __ ]
driving the car and one day it burned
down that's basically what happened and
ended up being a good thing because like
a month later i moved to new york and i
didn't have to deal with the car and
having a car when you live in new york
city is like having a kid that never
grows up and there's
people you know back then were
vandalizing it and all of that [ __ ] so
it ended up being like a good thing but
uh
look
yeah just keep your [ __ ] head up
you're only 25 years old and all of this
struggling that you're doing is gonna
build character
and uh and you won't have fears in life
because you've been all because you've
been where you've been
you know your sister someday if the rich
guy she's with
goes [ __ ] belly up she's not gonna
know how to survive
um not that i'm wishing that on her all
right overrated underrated dear billy
butterball
hey do the fat jokes all you want
i'm only half about a ball now uh
greetings from new hampshire oh it's
god's country up there
i'm currently on summer break from my
college and the podcast has been a great
way to pass the time on my drive to work
love the red rock special and thanks for
all of your great work anyway i wanted
to write into the podcast to give you to
give a suggestion for the overrated
underrated section
i think safety features in cars are
overrated hear me out he says i drive a
2009 model toyota and besides the airbag
there doesn't seem to be any safety
features of any kind and i don't think
i'm missing out
uh my parents drive newer cars and the
beeping when you back the car up or
cross over the lines on the road drives
me crazy
i think just cruising without any noise
other than the sound of a good old
classic rock album
is an underrated luxury
i love you talking about this 2009 like
you got a 19 [ __ ] 70
camaro or something that's how much
advancement has happened since then
um
anyways good old classic rock album is
an underrated luxury and that old
base model car is really all you need
you drive an old truck and loved cars so
i'm curious to see what your opinion is
on all the gadgets they're stuffing into
cars now thanks and have a good one
um
well when you have kids you love it and
when you get into an accident you do
love it but i will tell you uh what i
like about my car
is i do have the option of shutting it
off
one button just push it when it starts
going beep
i also like it when i'm parking
you know um i can tell you that i used
to be really good at parking and once
they got the backup cameras you sit so
low in the car it's like you really have
to be looking like
you know okay there's the line and then
you got to pick you got to pick an
object was like dead reckoning when
you're flying to park it because i can't
see the lines i got to like open the
door
and i was better at parking
like when i back my truck in it has no
backup lights or anything like that uh
cameras or anything like i'm right
between the lines when i drive the one
that has the cameras and the airbags and
all that i'm always a little bit off a
little too far over a little bit of an
angle
and i'm like [ __ ] and i gotta get back
in the car and all of that [ __ ] so
i don't know um i will say with all of
this technology because of this [ __ ]
chip
thing huh chip chip
remember will ferrell and uh
the outtakes for uh
ricky bobby
um i don't get how the what the [ __ ]
how'd that even happen there's like a
shortage of computer chips they're only
made in one place
and now you gotta wait like nine years
for a [ __ ] new car and uh all the old
cars
the value of them goes through the
[ __ ] roof
i don't know it's all the strange thing
i don't pretend to understand these
things um i personally
if i'm driving with my kids i like the
latest technology but if i'm driving by
myself
um
i love driving the old truck
i do uh
all right and that is it my friends once
again thank you to everybody that came
out to the uh the cosmo this weekend in
vegas
um
by the way my wife went out to go see
the uh usher show
last night at the was he at the paris i
forget where he's at but she said the
show was incredible so if you're in
vegas definitely check that out
if you're not going to brad garrett's
comedy club at the mgm shout out to brad
garrett all right that's it everybody
go [ __ ] yourselves and i will check in
on you
in uh
in a couple of days that's it go red sox
enjoy the all-star break nfl football
but it'll put it up it's only six weeks
away as a as is college football all
right that's it i'm done i'll talk to
you later